- [Mark] All right, Wendy.
Wendy, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I was born in Anaheim, California.
- [Mark] And tell me about your family.
You had both your parents?
- No, I don't know my real father.
Never met him, seen him in a picture.
I stayed with my mom.
Me and my two sisters in Buena Park.
- [Mark] How was your childhood?
- Huh?
- Not good.
I got child abused and I was the only one.
And I got taken away out of school.
And my sister got taken
away two weeks later.
- [Mark] What kind of stuff was going on?
- Huh?
- My mom was mentally retarded.
She got hit by a truck
on her fifth birthday
and it damage to her brain,
so she had a mind like a kid.
But I don't know why or understand why
she beat me all the time and not them.
I don't know, it was a trip.
I guess 'cause I look
like my father, I guess.
I don't know.
And I got taken away.
I went to McLaren Hall from there
and I went to different places.
Never stayed in one long
enough to go to school.
I was a chronic runaway.
And came over here to
this South Central LA
and I met this black man,
had to use the bathroom,
and I said, "Can I come
and live with you?"
He says, "Sure, honey."
I was on the porch the next
day with two paper bags.
From the age of 13 until he
passed away three years ago
and he took care of me.
But I experienced Figueroa Street,
wanted to see what was so-
- [Mark] So he was a
boyfriend or a pimp or?
- No, I've experienced pimp, yeah,
but a pimp can't do nothin' with my money
that I can't do with it.
You know what I'm sayin'?
How many of men tell me,
"Bitch, go out there and get my money."
"Bitch, I need you to
bring me this and that."
I don't need that shit.
You know, I've been oddball all my life.
And where I live right now,
all the kids, all the youngsters,
they respect me to the fullest,
call me moms and auntie.
I been kidnapped.
I've been stabbed.
Pushing a walker down the
street making my own money.
- [Mark] So you've been working Figueroa
for how many years?
- Huh?
- [Mark] You've been working
Figueroa for how many years?
- I've been working Figueroa
from age of 14 to now.
- [Mark] And how old are you today?
- I'll be 55 on the 26th of July.
You know, I had a rough life.
- [Mark] And you're still doin' it.
- Yeah.
To pay for my own room, you know.
I'm not young no more,
so they don't pick me up,
'cause I used to make
money when I was young.
But now I'm older, so they want the young,
booty girls now,
but I do have my regulars
and I do have friends
that just come by and toss me the money.
But it ain't for me no more, it ain't.
It's just getting too
dangerous and everything.
I don't want to experience
no more death situations
or anything no more in my life.
- [Mark] What kind of stuff have you seen?
- Have I seen?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I've seen so much out there.
So much killings.
Young girls, not even 16,
or some of them are not even that old,
out there on the street.
And I stop and I talk to them.
I say, well, they call me
moms or auntie out here.
And they're so beautiful.
So beautiful, little girls.
They can do somethin'
better with their life
instead of this.
And all they're looking for is love.
They're searching for somethin'
they're not getting at home.
A mother figure, father figure, somethin'.
And that's why they come to the streets.
They bump into dudes
and shit, thinking that,
you know, that ain't love baby.
They're just using you.
But they'll wake up when some
tragedy happens or whatever.
Like Amber, that's my girl.
There ain't nothing I won't do for her.
Because when I was sick,
she took care of me,
paid my rent, fed me.
And I love her, I'll take my
shirt off, I would die for her
because she's a good person.
But people take advantage of
her and stuff all the time,
but
that's my heart.
You know what I'm saying?
And I respect her to the fullest.
Right now I'm going through
some changing right now.
Then my birthday's coming up.
I'm going to see my twin
sister, I ain't seen since 2007.
That's all I want God to do,
is let me see her and I'm fine.
I have bone cancer right now.
- [Mark] Oh, you do.
- And without bone marrow,
I'm not gonna be able to survive too long.
You know what I'm saying?
And they're not goin' to
try to help find me none
or anything because, you know,
it's all about the money.
But God is letting me live,
and I really don't know
why I was even born.
'Cause this been my whole life.
And I feel like I'm being punished
for the sins of my ancestors or somethin'
because I ain't done nothin'
but got taken away for
child abuse and that was it.
And this is life,
that
came upon me, so.
But I'm very discreet.
I'm humble.
And I have a lot of love
in my heart for people.
Even though they do me
wrong, I still have love,
because it's within me.
I get mad, don't get me wrong.
But you know,
vengeance is his not mine
and karma's a motherfucker,
I'm still paying for crime
I did back in my days.
- [Mark] Do you have children, Wendy?
- I have three girls.
- [Mark] And did he raise them?
- I see one every day.
The other one in Kansas,
my oldest one, her brother
got killed out here.
He was only out here for two weeks
and that's the first time I've seen him
since I had him and her,
but she didn't come.
But she has resentment.
Or you know, it couldn't take decades
to build that bond with her
because they only knew me as an aunt.
They didn't know I was their mom
until my grandmother opened up her mouth.
And you know that I send
them money on holidays.
You know, when I call, I say,
"Let me speak to my daughter."
She get on the phone and say, "Hi."
I say, "Hi, baby, how you
doin', you need somethin'?"
She says, "No, I got
everything I need right now,
thank you."
She says, I'm gonna put you
on the phone with Aunt Toni."
And that's it, she don't
really talk to me too much.
I can understand that,
but she don't know why
I had to give them up.
I'd rather to give him to my
aunt than the state take over.
But I have another daughter name Summer.
She lives in California City.
And my youngest one, she's
high-maintenance baby,
but cheaper.
- [Mark] Are drugs a part of your life.
- I do drugs
occasionally,
but I don't do them like I used to,
because I know I have that cancer.
And I don't need nothin'
that's gonna make me sicker
and stuff, and I don't
really have a place to
stay right now
so,
it's hard for me.
I be trying to pay rent,
but they want $80 for
a fuckin' fleabag motel
and it ain't worth it to me,
you know what I'm saying?
But if I had to, I'd have to get one,
but I don't like roaming the streets,
like all night, all day.
There's too much shit out there
and drugs are killing
the motherfuckers off.
You know, it's all about drugs
and what they can get
from you, and that's it.
They don't really be
concerned about the person.
It's all about them.
- [Mark] Have you been in love before?
- Huh?
- I think I've been in love.
I couldn't really say, yeah.
My kid's father, I didn't
have feelings for none of them
except this one guy.
On a 109th and Broadway.
I don't know what it was,
but it was a month before
we even got intimate.
But when we did, oh my god, he woke me up.
He brought out the,
brought out me, you know?
And it's been a long time since
I felt like that with a man,
you know what I'm saying?
He just did things that I
would not let no other man do.
A lot things nasty or somethin' like that.
But he used beat me all the time.
He used to jump on me and
that's the only problem we had.
But I stayed with him for 12 years.
And I can't count on both hands,
how many times did we have sex.
But he started fucking
around with other woman.
I'd come home, catch him,
the bitch is naked and shit.
I don't care about what you do,
but you're going to respect me
and them bitches are too.
But yup, I fell real hard for him,
because he made me feel alive
again, you know, sexually.
It was awesome.
I fell hard for him, but
I didn't feel like that
with my kids father.
But I feel like that was
my first love really,
to tell you the truth,
because I ain't never had
feelings like that for no man.
Only him.
- [Mark] Was that the
best part of your life?
- He was a friend, I mean,
after that we became friends,
but he lives inside his own
apartment now and works.
But he only comes over there to see me.
- [Mark] But what was the
best point of your life?
- What do you mean?
- [Mark] When were you
happiest in your life?
- Let me tell you the truth.
I ain't never really
felt happy in my life.
You know, I really haven't.
That's a shame.
I'm a big kid right now, I
wanna do fun things, you know.
Go places that I ain't never been before.
I ain't never had a
birthday party in my life.
And she's going to make it happen too.
My girl, yeah, I'm gonna
have a little birthday.
I want a cake with party
hats and things you blow out.
And I don't care who else don't come.
You don't have to bring me no gifts.
I just want a real friend around.
And there's only two girls that
I know are my real friends.
Quickfire and her.
Anybody that says they'll
go to the hospital with me
to see if their bone
marrow will match mine.
That's a friend.
And I know she's my friend, you know.
Really, she just stresses out too much.
And I don't know if she
told you about this dude,
Anthony or whoever he is.
But she really cares about this man,
but he don't give fuck and
she got beat up by a dude.
Did you see her?
I thought just it was her
lip, but when I seen her face,
that fuckin', oh I had rage in me.
I wish I woulda known who this dude was.
I swear.
And obviously I was, it comes
along with the territory.
I been trying to watch out
for her, as best as I can,
'cause she's young and beautiful.
She's confused also.
Confusion, you don't
know what real love is,
'cause that's not real love.
I've been through abuse with all my men,
except my youngest daughter's
daddy (indistinct).
Abusive, and until you stop that abuse,
the cycle's gonna keep continuing.
Continuing.
She's a beautiful girl
and she's got a good heart
but she lets people misuse it.
And that's the only thing that, yeah.
- [Mark] What do you think the cause is
of the self-destructive
lifestyle that these women
that work Figueroa have?
You think it's the childhood?
Do you think the abuse?
- It's their childhood.
It's somethin' that they're
not getting at home.
That's why each in their own way,
their getting the searching for love.
And I'm still searching in a way.
And you know, like I gotta have love.
I want somebody to love me
for who I am, for Wendy.
Not because of the way I look or whatever.
I've tried so hard.
Put Preparation H under my eyes
so on the wrinkles to see it be gone.
And so many things I wanted to do.
But people don't have the
time to help nobody no more.
So I just give it to God and
let him handle everything.
I still doubt him because
of the lifestyle I live.
And I've been praying and
crying out for help to him,
but in his time he'll help whenever.
But I gotta make them steps first.
I gotta to take a step
before he takes two.
If I'm not doing it and I'm
not trying to help myself,
why would anybody else wanna try to help?
I got to be the one to do it, you know?
And I thank God to this day.
After all the shit I've been
through when I got kidnapped,
oh my god.
He cut all my hair off
and shaved me bald headed.
Tied me up.
I had a cast on each arm,
a tube in my stomach,
my ribs are still fucked up.
And I lost six pints of blood
and I have 170 stitches in my head.
He fucked me up.
And I didn't see the pictures
until I went to court.
And when I seen me looking
like that, when the beat,
Oh my god, I just, you know.
He's out of prison now.
I see him every day.
His name ain't Gabro no
more, it's Godfather.
And you know, he says he didn't do that,
he didn't this, they did it.
I know what happened.
But he took me to the
hospital and they said,
"Who did this to you?"
And I said, "The guy who brought me here."
And the bitches, I didn't
say nothing, I don't know.
But one of them got, her mom
worked at the police station,
so she made him testify
on my behalf against him.
But he's out.
He tries to say hi and stuff.
I'll say hi and stuff,
but that doesn't mean you
have to talk about it.
Nothin' we gotta say.
And he keeps saying,
"The only reason why I didn't
kill you when I got out,
is because you stopped him
from beating me up on the road.
But they were beating him up so bad.
I couldn't take it anymore.
I said, "Stop, that's enough," you know.
What he did to me, I
could've let them continue,
but that's not my heart.
You know, it's not within me.
He did his time, ah, whatever.
I don't hold grudges or whatever.
I just move on with my life.
I don't think about it.
I got so much, I bury so deep
that I don't let it come to the surface.
And when I feel like it's
coming to the surface
I get away from everything,
all the negativity
and just be by myself, you know, space.
You know, because I
don't wanna be going off.
And I go off on the wrong
person the shit because of that.
I hope I'm not boring you.
Am I?
- No, no.
- Yeah, so.
I've lived a rough life.
I'll be 55 on the 26th of July.
And I'm leaving this area.
- [Mark] Is it a difficult
transition to go,
like when you were
younger in your twenties
or whatever thirties, you
were probably in demand
and made a lot more money?
- Oh, I made a killing.
Everybody tells me that.
They say, "Wendy, you were the
finest white bitch out here.
You had motherfuckers circling
corners damn near wrecking
to get your ass.
And you know what though?
And you are fine bitch,
you were beautiful."
But you know what?
I never took the time to even see that.
You know, and when I
hear them tell me that
it's a trip because I
never thought about myself,
about nothing like that, you know?
Most of the time, every man I had,
they were all gang bang retaliator.
The only one that wasn't really hard, hard
was my youngest daughter's daddy.
All he did was sell dope
and shit, and whatever.
But the other one, that
one, my twin's father,
first time and I was with him.
He swore up and down I was
sucking some man's dick
on the freeway.
Chased me all over.
I say, "Go there and pull up in the line."
I pulled up in my mom's yard
and she kept hearing this noise.
"Man, I just want my girl
outta the car 'cause this one,
I'm not gonna rob you
or do nothing to you,
I just want my woman up outta the car."
He said, "Get out, get out."
I said, "No, take off, he's
going to kill us like that."
And I got out and he grabbed me and said,
"Why, Wendy why you want
to do me like this?"
He said, "Take me by my father's house,
I'm killing this bitch."
You know?
And he's too possessive.
If a man said hi, he'll say,
"Oh, what'd yo do, you
fucked her before or what?"
You know, he tripped like
that, that's how he was.
And he used to beat, jump on
me and shit all the time too.
Yeah, it's a trip.
But I had a couple of good men friends.
- [Mark] Your life has been a string of
abusive relationships it sounds like.
- No, not, I mean-
- [Mark] Your mom.
- I thought that
relationship, but then what?
I just dig in and deal with the shit.
Right now I ain't have had a
man in my life for so long.
I really don't care, you know.
I'm just trying to focus on myself
and get my life together.
'Cause before I die,
I want to be right with
myself and him, you know?
And I refuse to die on the streets.
My family, they're prejudice.
They're full-bloodied Italians, Sicilian.
They are prejudice.
And the only person that's
not is my Aunt Toni in Kansas.
I can call her up and say,
"Aunt Toni, I'll suck a dick
and fucking announce
it at your front door."
She's says, "Oh, honey I
love you, don't do that."
She said, "Honey, have
you ever smoked crack?"
I said, "You're not gonna be mad at me
if I tell you the truth, now?"
She said, "No."
I said, "Yes, I have."
I could talk to her and
she doesn't discriminate
or anything against me.
And the rest of them,
no,
they ain't no good.
I didn't have to live my life like this.
Somebody could have
taken me in from family.
They took my twin sister
and my sister Sam.
So what's up with me?
That's why I feel like I'm being punished
for third generation.
I really do, because you know,
my family, they're not rich
but they're well off.
Just put it like that.
Yeah.
That's all.
- [Mark] All right, Wendy.
Well, thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- You're welcome.
- [Mark] Very interesting.
- I gave you the whole
truth though about my life
and there's more, but it's okay.
And I thank you for meeting you.
It was a pleasure and God Bless.
- [Mark] All righter, thank you.
- Yeah, I just want to get
back and get me some rest.